[Music]
Rachel welcome how you doing I'm
fantastic
Rachel Lindsay's season of The
Bachelorette is just getting started
but we're already thinking about yep
bachelor in paradise you'll probably see
me there mailed a bun you never know
along with the possibility of jasmine
and chase there will also be some
suitors from a Rachel season mixed in
absolutely some of the guys I mean that
all right if I was going on paradise
this year with something I am I don't
think there'd still be any competition
but you know yes sadly it's looking like
some of our other bachelor nation faves
won't be there
I say ever I just said not this year and
I don't know yet you'll have pregnancy
I guess there's like two three weeks
still filming I mean unless they pull
something crazy move and buy me on you
know I don't know but everyone seems on
board for the newly announced bachelor
Winter Games let's go Fred what are
living what are olympics ooh yes Briana
I have a feeling they're probably don't
want me for that thing yeah that'd be
crazy I'll probably end up doing it I
don't want to do it I'll probably have
to do it I'm probably bribed me in some
sort of way competition exactly
no I'm killer be killed here I'm like
totally an athlete
[Music]
you